[Musica]
back my brother
allora ragazzi oggi
c'è allora ragazzi sua mini già amnesia
come credi si voglia siccome hanno fatto
una custom story della madonna di un
gioco al mese dabo otto anni va bene
secondo me il modo migliore per
rievocare il 2012 2013 più o meno quella
lì per lì e giocare questa notte già
partita la strage tra l'altro con acqua
cioè una custom storia anche narrata
cioè fantastico per ritrovare alcune
antidolorifici nella washroom ma e se
abiti ad hogwarts non è colpa mia
fratello c'erano solo dato è solo dei
fucili che non sono male possiamo
prendere la candela agli occhiali che
sei proprio harry potter la bibla la
bibla mi manca madonna ragazzi che bello
è rigiocata da venezia tra questo lo
bagno proprio lui non mi sembra proprio
il bagno ovviamente dovevi che gli altri
lo ridice zio eccolo qua la classica
cucina proprio incredibile poi power
gioca alla playstation allora
the master bedroom questo è il master
bagno
dove che ti ritieni antidolorifici
fratello non vedere
spaccato tutto c'è una mela marcia sono
io eccolo qua
l'ho preso
perchè sono appena magnati che potevo
non ho capito cosa hai detto zio ma va
bene prova mia grazie
devo andare a vedere quel racket di che
cosa si tratta non si sono sta cosa
voglia dire racket prova bene
alla lettera ok dopo il mare all'estero
ad est di londra esiste la magione lor
del murò bolelli il secondo che cazzo
vogliono perché io sono un investigatore
la [ __ ] per cosa sfidiamo da lì è vedere
che cosa fosse cromwell poche parole va
bene a pato sono un po sherlock e io in
realtà e ho anche una tigre sul davanti
a letto ok
immagino che non mi lasceranno in pace
che mi faranno andare lo stesso nella
islands prove cioè data dopo l'oceano
l'anoressia
danimarca
porca [ __ ] però non me lo dire così e
anche ho dimenticato il gas acceso di
breuer
va bene va ad oggi bisogno
va bene va bene vado sto andando sto
andando cioè entrato godzilla in casa
cosa abbiamo bisogno per il nostro
viaggio di sicuro un paio di polmoni per
gridare perché ci ha pensato infatti un
cuore di ricambio perché l'infarto
comprenda che quel e vestiti cose va beh
devo prendere vestiti la lanterna è la
chiave di casa perché sto poi non entro
più o meno dai vestiti molto bene a
posto lanterna ci abbiamo
alternato e chiacchiera troppo
stefano ghezze vario ormai glide
sbilancia il pan europei da sé con
separa ogni tutela della interna e
dell'entella gli slider del coniglio
caputa di 6 calmo però quanto casinò
lanterne
eccola qua
abbiamo la terra raga manca solo la
chiave di casa che non ho il mio che
stiamo a credo al piano di sotto e che
quel punto
che di casa che ogni casa
chiave di casa lo spaccando un po tutto
la fa niente non sa eccola qua no cos'è
questo scatola l'esca l'acciarino non è
chiarita dove la chiave di casa madonna
sarà qua no face dell'olio
uscire lo stesso manca la chiavica
ragazzone solidi ritieni le cose tu
il side view d altra parte del mondo tu
sei 20 alle spalle c melo chiuso dentro
che giusto e un eagle gay o siamo
arrivati al no proprio su scelte sono
appena fuori da casa mi piace tutto il
tragitto è una via un po di merda la
vita però ok e vabbè a parte ma è tutto
allegro cuoa meno male devo andare a
sinistra e napoli non posso basta vita
se te lo dico sei un investigatore
privato ai fattori sordi negli anni è
comprata a milano a casa ma che cazzo
vuoi ma non lo so io devo piaceva alla
libreria poi dove andare madonna si sono
sbattuti un 4 quarto bella sala pa
quanto si sono sbattuti a pasta roba
pazzesco tra questa libreria zio non lo
so c'è scritto libreria da che parte del
suo
ok se ben 9 feb era questa la libre non
ho capito dove sono andato ma era giusto
così come
salute
ma che cazzo ma cosa evita di guardare i
nemici un ubriaco nudo ma cosa ha
ficcato un ritardo che la metà bastava
saluto ed è un nemico cioè la cacca al
massimo è uno ad aiutare comunque la
porta sul retro a parte lo zio che
erutta e fa le cose di qua dovrebbe
essere qua infatti si aperta per questo
ci faceva di notte in una libreria lo
zio uso trova bene
ok tutto tranquillo guardano male
io non ho effettivamente capito se qua
che devo investigare se devi investigare
dall'altra parte del mondo da dove siamo
adesso secondo me è già un posto dove
potremo evitare di scrivere come
consiglio dietro da renzi io propri
colori
giorno
allegro quale mi piace l'atmosfera che
crea amnesia che sempre come se fossimo
nelle fauci di satana però va bene
quello è un classico registro gioco
dovrebbero andare esattamente dove che
prendo il libro e mi serve cioè sono un
po tanti oh my god i
ragazzi istituto dei rumori o
veste che i brother and est e baiano
giga nei allieva bocelli a
capitana che ho notato anch'io perché mi
sono ubriacato c'erano bagnasco bene
c'è qua non c è conosciuto c'è una nota
via
tagete nuda quanti e chi voglio
chiudermi quale si può grazie mi ha
detto non si può chiamare è allora
prendi lo so perché c'è quello nudo di
prima a quanti problemi questo gioco la
gente nuda ma perché c'è un ubriaco nudo
che erutta è pazzesco tutto quella cosa
stai lontano fai schifo
che altro lo sgabello in faccia per la
qual cosa sto vedendo ma che gioco è ma
anche gioco e begu lei
ma
ma c'è una scatola nel cuba aveva
bellissimo ragazzi 10 su mi piace subito
al vino ragazza subito stefano non posso
portarti con me devo scappare da solo
tasto tifo che ovvero
chiudi la porta certo modo bastardo e
vabbè
ma veramente la porta è aperta se
veramente un primato marcio poter
rientrare lo stesso la porta era aperta
poter rientrare uguale ma poi perché un
ubriaco dovrebbe picchiarmi ma che cazzo
vuoi ma non ho capito che gioco sta
giocando
caput el'abbiamo impossibile caso cioè
ragazzi cioè io veramente la cosa più io
non ho mai visto niente di così non
senso della mia vita già basta seria ma
perché devi non per le cose ma cos'è il
quale i problemi ai
ma non lo so parte ho fatto il giro
certa cosa non ha senso
che la porta cioè non riusciva ad
entrare l'asta porta hanno sfondato
l'altro a chiamare un capitolo tutto
quanto quanto ai di quoziente
intellettivo 0 ma lo so che ansia le
vivere è rimasto incastrato lì non ho
parole possa andare lì sopra ti prego
grazie e mettiti delle mutande che fai
schifo
capito è sempre una merda ambulanze
c'erano ragazzi non posso passare da più
lista porta per fare più di quella porta
va da ragazzi tanto il tutto questo mi
ha riportato all'entrata quindi l'uomo
nudo se n'è andato
e ho finito io anche a posto mi ha
sbloccato la porta mentre doveva fine di
parlare sono uscito e stato bello
simpatici e quelli nudi che ti vogliono
braccia però lasciamo perdere cioè non
no anche nuovo dai anche no è comunque
anche questo è un posto allegro sono
contento raga ma domanda stupida ma tu
che abiti qua
quando sei andato su immobiliare.it per
cercare l'affitto dove cazzola ricercato
su affitto cioè spero chiedo comunque a
parte le finestre spaccate dovremo
arrivare a questo almeno
dei sei a questa la sequenza del ha
quindi io pensavo di dover prendere una
barca andare oltreoceano ho parlato di
oceano e allora ho letto male il giorno
in teoria non è certo germi interessa
poco dove stiamo andando interessa tanto
non ricevere infarti gratuiti ma questo
non me lo posso promettere probabile
quindi di ragazzi questo era il primo
episodio di amnesia 10 m faremo un altro
episodio perché sicuramente cioè a me
piace tantissimo ma poi non avete idea
di che cosa è successo ero già
registrato a bere lo spoiler che hanno
vistosamente la mente mente cosa
succederà incredibile sto gioco è
tornato dopo dieci anni ma li merita
tutti questi complimenti perché fa
ancora un sacco di povero comunque
ragazzi fatemi sapere che ne pensate
iscritte a cannes ha lasciato questo li
na cecilia poi sempre ad un passo visto
dai ragazzi
[Musica]